you wrote this book yearbook and and so
many that's nice
i do there's so many times i read
someone's book and i have to read it
because i gotta then interview them and
maybe the the book's okay but it's not
it's not something that i would
necessarily talk about a lot and then
what happens is i i
get past it in the interview and i don't
really touch on it that much i read your
book
and then uh you and i did the podcast
yeah and
that's all i could talk about it was so
good fantastic his book
if you have not read his book thank you
and you have this so many great stories
but you wrote about working with snoop
dogg
i did a fantastic story thank you yeah
um
speaking of weed i was uh i we made a
film called this is the end
um around eight years ago
in that film yeah there's a song that
craig robinson
sings called take your panties off which
i would argue has not aged well
but uh we thought it would be fun uh if
at the end of the movie there was like a
more produced version of the song
that was like a real song and then what
if snoop dogg was on the song was what
we thought and we asked snoop dogg and
he's like yeah i'll be in a song called
take your panties off that doesn't seem
like
a stretch for snoop dogg um and so
we met in the recording booth him and
craig were there we were all smoking
we'd snoop had a man who rolled joints
for him that was his only job that was
truly i can confirm that because the
times i've been
around snoop i have seen that happen yes
he has a man who does that for him like
that is a human's
job which uh is honestly like if i
wasn't a comedian what i would want to
do with my life
and so um he wrote his uh hook and he
was performing and then
um i was like you know it'd be great
snoopers if you could sing a verse
uh on the song a rap verse um because
i'm very cool that's what i called it
could you sing a rap verse
and he was like uh you know i wasn't
planning on doing a verse i was just
planning on singing the hook and i was
like oh it'd be great uh
if you could do the verse and he kind of
puts his head down
and he's like okay i'll do it and then
he looks over at one of his guys
who's standing by the door and he kind
of narrows his gaze and he goes hey
bring in the hose
at which point a man with a garden hose
did not come into the room
but instead around five women dressed
like strippers came into the room
um and they danced he they played the
beat and they danced around for like 20
minutes as he wrote uh
a verse on his blackberry um and as soon
as he was done writing the verse
he kind of with a wave of the hand like
dismissed the hose
and it flooded my head with questions
[Laughter]
like the weird thing he wasn't planning
on writing a rap
so if he needs his army of hoes to
appear
whenever he writes a wrap does he have
the round just in case
like that's what i couldn't believe yeah
it's like he has an army of muse that he
busses around
in case someone's like hey could you
write a rap he's like yeah bring in the
hose okay dance
but that must be very expensive because
not everyone's asking him to write raps
all the time
where were they i didn't see them before
this i didn't know
i don't know where he was keeping that
hot air hot air balloon yeah i think
they
they travel in a hot air balloon and he
wants us down there
set it down they release the they come
down they repel in every time
um and uh overall uh i shouldn't be
saying ho
is also something that uh i bet probably
just to make you
you know just to make use of them he
probably does it for emails and stuff
yeah exactly
two of them come in for an email for a
tweet for a text just maybe one like
okay you know but i did i was actually
asked him once like why did you do that
with the hose and he's like gotta make
sure it's
he bumping an answer irrefutable